sordin this seems to be even more and
more pressing with the proliferation of
artificial intelligence robotics genetic
engineering neural prosthetics
nanotechnology and the race between
China and the United States and Russia
colonize Mars what is going how do we
actually end up coming to a global
consensus on what to do as eight people
equate in wealth to the bottom 12 I
don't see why we have to have an
intelligent discussion about this
because on the one hand it's pretty
obvious that modern economies are doing
a damn good job of lifting people
rapidly out of abject poverty okay but
at the same time the inequality of it of
economic the economic inequality by some
measures at least is increasing and that
does have this destabilizing effect and
so then the question is what do you do
about it
well it's really hard because
in a meritocracy part of that's driven
by
aggregation by intelligence
and then that's likely exaggerated by
mutational power because a really smart
person with a computer is way smarter
than a really smart person without a
computer and is real and is way smarter
than a person who isn't so smart either
with or without a computer right so the
computational technology looks like it's
a multiplier like I'm sure many of you
already know now because there is a huge
difference between someone who can
really use a computer in someone who's
barely computer literate and lots of way
more people are barely computer literate
literate than you know